Louis last week we had to skip my most
popular pictures on Instagram segment it
was crazy last week you know that it was
completely out of control uh yeah I
don't have to tell you so I want to get
to it this week and of course i'm on
instagram at david dot pakman i went
kayaking last week on the charles river
and i took a selfie which i really don't
do because i am sort of against the
entire concept but this was really the
only practical way to take this picture
this is quite a picture with the
exception that i had the phone held
vertically and i always complain when
people do this when taking videos as
opposed to landscape why why use
portrait mode I don't know why I did it
but I did you know I and to be perfectly
frank with you I am not that good on the
water I get a little bit seasick and I
get worried that my kayak is going to
get flipped over by motorized boat that
is passing by and in my uh uh anxiety
about this I took a portrait picture and
you know I IV anxiety is palpable the
anxiety is probable in the picture I'm
it I'm trying to look sort of calm but
I'm really not because uh you know when
you're down there at water level uh and
the motorized boat comes by and you see
that wake current coming towards you I
panic a little bit I really do i'm just
not good on the water i don't do that
well on the water and did you stumble
across any corpses uh on the charles
none whatsoever the smell of the water
was perfectly suitable inappropriate i
didn't smell anything unusual or
anything like that that was the second
most popular picture last week on my
Instagram account here is the most
popular picture from last week and I'm
starting to notice a theme this is me
holding a three-week-old baby okay the
horror anything baby related seems to do
stunningly well and I don't know if this
is just on Instagram or or on my
personal account but this is the most
popular picture I've ever posted and
some people saying I look incredibly
uncomfortable here holding this three
week old human other said everything up
to and including i will make a really
good mom someday which is kind of an
unusual comment to make but that that's
okay uh what is it Louis about babies
and Instagram that just does so well
I don't know but this is this must apply
to all of social media yeah it applies
with puppies and kittens is where I am
any type of small cute animal I suppose
this is a small cute animal so same
thing yeah maybe so uh sure i find
mummies and kids to be far more charming
than little babies half of course you
kidding me all they do is the crap in
puke and cry isn't that the same thing
puppies do too no they play okay and you
can interact with uh david dot Pakman on
instagram i also have an instagram only
promo code for membership i'm not going
to mention it here i posted it this
morning along with a picture of the new
website check it out uh instagram only
membership coupon code